let's talk about the neo-nazis those
crazy wacky guys they're back they never
go away then we're gonna find out about
their Facebook page in a second this
this story is so bonkers it's ridiculous
a man living in North Dakota
his name's Craig Cobb he lives in the
town of Leith which is a huge town it
has 19 people he wants it to become an
all-white town a neo-nazi town where
they'll be free to do all their neo-nazi
box socials
now the thing is guess how many black
people currently live in I yes yeah one
you're right there's one guy so
basically they're trying to get the one
black guy at it obviously this is
completely insane he wants anyone who
lives on his property so on this town
that they'd be required to fly a racial
banner 24 hours a day such as a Nazi
flag they'd also be required to try to
import more responsibly radical hardcore
white nationalism Oh white people is
there anything I mean I mean reading
this story and then reading that he had
been buying up these properties so he
could expand his property and then
invite his white friends hey come on you
can come live on my property I've been
buying it up it's so scary I mean I'm
surprised that the one black guy that
lives in that town actually made a
comment at the end of that story it's
like well hopefully it's not gonna hurt
anybody you know I'm not faking man he's
got balls to stab me I wouldn't want to
leave either and that's my town it's not
you know you're trying to create
something else that I was here first
it's where I live but that's gonna be
the only cool guy in town can you
imagine a town of just white people up
sounds Martin
yes I can imagine okay that would be
pretty boring and imagine it yeah anyway
but first dance clubs ever this guy by
the way is such an [ __ ]
he got kicked out of Canada basically
for being an [ __ ] yeah that's Ricky
go to Europe first and then you guys
there back got kicked out of you
so he goes to Canada Canada goes you're
too big of an [ __ ] to live here so he
goes to North Dakota where there's no
one lives there yeah so now we my
Norwegian family like all when they kind
of migrated over the United States took
over the Dakotas cuz they're like great
it's like Norway and nobody wants a
Norwegian I probably a lot of tweeting
ZUP in the Dakotas but it's funny that
they took over that land because it's
cold and rocky and nobody wants to live
there and they're like we'll take it
what price the other half Filipino Oh in
Spanish yeah yeah well they're not good
they don't want any Filipino there
either I'm sure you with all the white
Norwegians yeah but playing devil's
advocate here for just a second
should we just allow this to be because
you know what if this crazy white
supremacist wants all his white
supremacist buddies to go live with him
over there maybe why get out of her why
he was able to buy a house for $5,000 in
the city yeah and all I can think of
this once this guy moves in values are
going down he doesn't want any gay
people living there but doesn't he know
that when gay people move next door to
you gentrification the whole place yeah
but really should we just like should we
not even talk about this in because let
them if they want to separate themselves
and be very isolated up there because I
mean who really wants to live in North
Dakota I don't yeah thank you
so I mean he's not breaking any laws as
of right now I mean he's just trying to
gather all his white neo-nazi friends to
go live with them and that whatever
leave the the crazy kook heads up there
by themselves how ironic had to come
back to the United States and
multicultural countries we can have his
hate yeah and the white countries they
wouldn't allow it so much even though
Canada is a lot more multicultural than
we think but I forgot my second point
you had something there's something that
will get you around to it all right well
I mean I see this as sort of let let the
guy have his white I was just want to
say it's good we did so now we can be
like identified when I see you like a
skinhead like oh good I don't I know did
not go near you you're not gonna trick
me I'm not gonna walk over to you and
say
nice thing to you and you go hey how
about those [ __ ] you ever have that
have like all [ __ ] stop it I didn't know
that was coming so it's like guys who
wear the the American flag looks like I
I know you're an [ __ ] already I don't
need to meet you so that's what it's
good to see those people you keep them
away from you yeah you know we can
thread all the stories we've done here
together because I'm pretty sure some of
the people that are moving to North
Dakota this guy are the anonymous
commenters we talked about earlier
there's definitely white supremacists
love anonymous comment evil spew their
hate wherever they can find it forum
they they absolutely will but we know
you guys won't and that's why we love
you so comment like Vasiliy an tweet and
that's Jimmy Dore I'm Dave Rubin we'll
do this again next week barring World
War three okay